a Pakistani court has sentenced former
prime minister Imran Khan to 10 years in
prison for revealing State Secrets this
was another blow to Khan who was ousted
in a no confidence vote in Parliament in
April 2022 and is currently serving a
three-year prison sentence in a
corruption case authorities say Khan and
his party Deputy who also received a
10-year sentence have the right to
appeal the ruling his legal team says
they are planning to appeal the
conviction before the Islamabad High
court on Wednesday this ruling comes
ahead of the February 8th parliamentary
elections in Pakistan a vote con is
barred from running
[Music]
it
hon